Transcription: eya ayadi
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Est-ce que vous avez l’impression
de choisir la musique que vous écoutez ?
Les films que vous regardez ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que Netflix
fait de vous
de meilleurs amateurs du cinéma
ou WAZE de meilleurs navigateurs ?
Est-ce que vous pensez qu’Amazon fait
de vous de meilleurs consommateurs ?
Tous les services que je viens d’évoquer
utilisent massivement
l’intelligence artificielle,
du sol au plafond.
Et que ce soit volontaire ou involontaire,
systématiquement,
c’est en réduisant nos choix,
notre capacité d’action
et notre libre arbitre.
Et pour moi, ce qui est encore plus grave,
c’est que ces services
nous ne nous rendent pas meilleurs
dans nos activités.
Et je pense, aujourd’hui,
qu’il faut que cela change.
[Que fait l’intelligence artificielle
pour vous ?]
Alors, bien sûr,
l’intelligence artificielle fascine.
Elle est partout.
Quand on y pense, ça convoque
des personnages emblématiques
comme Steve Jobs ou Yann Le Cun,
Cocorico !
Ça convoque des scénarios
de science-fiction
comme dans Westworld ou Her.
Et surtout, ça convoque la Silicon Valley
avec ses promesses d’un monde meilleur.
Moi le premier,
j’adore l’intelligence artificielle.
Je m’appelle Christophe Tricot,
j’ai 41 ans.
J’adore développer des logiciels,
ce qui m’a conduit à devenir informaticien
puis chercheur
en intelligence artificielle
et enfin entrepreneur.
Aujourd’hui, je suis très fier d’avoir
cofondé et dirigé la Forge.
La Forge est un startup studio
qui a une mission :
démocratiser les meilleures
expertises médicales
grâce à l’intelligence artificielle.
Concrètement,
on accompagne, on investit
dans les entreprises
pour les aider à développer des produits
qui utilisent l’intelligence artificielle.
Par exemple, on aide des ophtalmos
à faire de meilleurs diagnostics,
y compris dans des logiques
et des problématiques de déserts médicaux.
On aide aussi ces mêmes ophtalmos
à soigner la cataracte
pour que leurs patients,
quand ils partent,
n’utilisent plus de lunettes.
On travaille aussi à aider les médecins,
à faire de la médecine préventive.
On utilise l’intelligence artificielle
pour que les individus
restent des individus
et ne deviennent pas des patients.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai l’occasion et la chance
de vous partager
et de vous révéler peut-être
ce qui, pour moi, est la face sombre
est la face
sombre de l’intelligence artificielle.
Steve Jobs disait que l’informatique était
la meilleure invention de l’humanité,
parce que pour lui,
c’était comme des vélos pour l’esprit.
Moi, j’aime beaucoup cette image
que l’informatique en général
et l’intelligence artificielle, qui est
une des branches les plus avancées de l’IA
permettent aux individus d’aller
plus vite plus loin, comme avec nos vélos.
Mais aujourd'hui, force est de constater
qu'en entreprise, ce n'est pas le cas.
Force est de constater que quand
on utilise l’intelligence artificielle,
on fait ce que j’appelle
des calculettes sous stéroïdes.
C’est-à-dire qu’on utilise
l’intelligence artificielle
pour améliorer ce que font
les organisations.
Elles, elles vont plus vite, plus loin,
par exemple, et je trouve ça génial,
en un clic, vous pouvez calculer
le risque d’une personne
avant de lui accorder un prêt ou pas.
Ou YouTube, par exemple,
je pense que vous connaissez bien,
en un clic, même moins le temps
d’un clic, ils sont capables de choisir
la bonne vidéo à mettre à la fin d’une
autre vidéo pour qu’on reste scotché.
C’est génial !
Mais je vous mets au défi, aujourd’hui,
vous aurez le temps d’y réfléchir après,
à trouver une application de
l’intelligence artificielle qui vous rende
meilleurs quand vous l’utilisez.
Aujourd’hui, pour cette “lettre à demain”
j’ai envie de proposer une alternative
à ce que l’on fait avec
l’intelligence artificielle.
Et cette alternative, elle s’articule
autour de trois principes :
le premier, ça vous paraît évident
maintenant,
c’est que il faut se focaliser
sur le savoir-faire.
Si vous partez du principe que vous voulez
créer des vélos pour l'esprit,
si vous partez du principe que
vous voulez déporter,
dans des logiciels avec de l’IA,
un savoir-faire
d’abord, il faut l’identifier,
de quoi on parle.
Ensuite, une fois
ce savoir-faire identifié,
vous vous en servirez pour identifier
les données que vous voulez exploiter.
On dit que la data,
c’est le pétrole de l’IA,
mais grâce au savoir-faire, vous
allez savoir quelles données utiliser
ou ne pas utiliser,
pourquoi et comment.
Par exemple, si vous voulez travailler
sur la gestion de talents,
vous prenez les données d’une entreprise
en matière des ressources humaines,
vous trouverez des traces
de son savoir-faire
en matière de recrutement,
de gestion du personnel
Ensuite, ce savoir-faire
que vous avez identifié,
il va vous permettre de choisir
les technologies d'intelligence
artificielle.
L’IA, c’est un ensemble
de techniques et de technologies
qu’on assemble pour simuler
des comportements intelligents,
simuler l'intelligence.
Aucune intelligence là-dedans.
Prenez l’exemple
de vos enceintes connectées.
Je ne pense pas
que vous les considériez intelligentes.
Pourtant, elles assemblent
plein de techno,
reconnaissance vocale, synthèse vocale,
système expert, etc.
Grâce au savoir-faire identifié,
vous allez donc choisir les bonnes data,
leur donner du sens,
et choisir les bonnes technos.
Par exemple, si vous avez plein de data,
vous allez utiliser le fameux
machine learning, l’apprentissage machine
pour extraire là aussi
des traces du savoir-faire.
Donc, premier principe
il faut se focaliser sur le savoir-faire.
C’est l’alpha et l’oméga
des applications de l’IA.
Deuxième principe, si vous voulez faire
des vélos pour l’esprit,
vous devez développer les applications
qui ont pour but
de transférer ce savoir-faire.
Là, vous allez dire, c’est simple.
Il suffit d'assister l'utilisateur.
C’est vrai, c’est ce qu’on fai
tous les jours dans plein de domaines,
encore faut il bien le faire.
Et là, je vous suggère,
je vous propose trois contraintes.
La première, c'est d'assister
sans infantiliser.
Infantiliser, c’est qu’il n’y a pas
de résultat magique,
une application qui vous donne un résultat
sans vous expliquer pourquoi,
elle ne vous aide pas.
Le banquier derrière son guichet, qui voit
une note avant d’accorder un crédit
si on ne lui dit pas pourquoi,
doù vient cette note,
ça ne fait pas un meilleur banquier.
Donc, il ne faut pas infantiliser,
il faut donner les clés pour comprendre.
Deuxième contrainte, quand vous allez
concevoir votre application,
vous devez assister sans contraindre.
Il faut que l’utilisateur soit capable
d’assembler ces outils
pour supporter son activité
et donc développer son savoir-faire.
Ce serait, vu qu’on est sur “lettres à
demain”, ce serait par exemple des GPS
où vous pouvez donner vos préférences
en termes de conduite,
les routes que vous voulez prendre,
les villes que vous voulez éviter,
plutôt que de nous enfermer
dans un seul usage.
Dernière contrainte,
il ne faut pas enfermer les utilisateurs.
Prenez l’exemple de nos smartphones,
bourrés d’applications
qui utilisent massivement
l’intelligence artificielle.
Mais ils nous empêchent de passer
d’une application à une autre,
alors que si on veut développer
nos savoir faire,
si on veut être meilleur
avec l’intelligence artificielle,
il faudrait qu’on puisse
exploiter tout ce potentiel.
Et soyons fous, ce serait par exemple
passer facilement votre profil de Spotify
à Apple Music.
D’un service de gestion de vidéo
à un autre.
Aujourd’hui, ce n’est pas possible.
Si vous avez identifié les bons
savoir-faire, les data, les technos
que vous avez l’intention de développer
une application qui va assister
dans la transmission de ces savoir-faire,
on arrive au troisième principe.
[Principe #3: Former le cercle
vertueux de l’IA]
Ce principe, c’est de former ce qu’on
appelle le cercle vertueux de l’IA.
Parce que si vous m’avez suivi,
on veut déporter dans des algos
une part de nos savoir-faire
pour le transmettre aux utilisateurs
pour l’utiliser, mais il est important que
les utilisateurs puissent lever le capot
et regarder ce qui se passe.
Alors, pour corriger
quand il y a des erreurs, ça c’est évident
et avec l’IA, il y a toujours des erreurs,
comme avec les humains.
Mais plus important, peut-être,
permettre d’ouvrir le capot, c’est
permettre aux utilisateurs de découvrir
de nouveaux enseignements.
La machine reste bête, mais par exemple,
on a un projet en ophtalmologie,
on fait des diagnostics.
Le diagnostic, on part
des signes, symptômes,
facteurs de risques,
et le médecin nous fait le diagnostic.
Quand on permet à ces praticiens
de regarder sous le capot,
ils découvrent en fait que la machine
a fait des corrélations
entre des signes, symptômes et maladies.
Ça devient génial,
car il n’y a pas d’intelligence
dans les corrélations
faites par la machine,
mais ça permet aux humains
qui l’utilisent de voir
qu’il y a peut-être des nouveaux
diagnostics et nouvelles maladies.
Je vous assure, par expérience,
que si vous mettez en place ces mécanismes
pour former ce cercle vertueux,
la complémentarité
homme machine est évidente.
Donc, si vous appliquez
ces trois principes,
se focaliser, quel savoir-faire
on veut démultiplier,
on design, on conçoit une application
dans le but de le transmettre.
Et sous le capot, on met en place
des mécanismes pour les utilisateurs
pour qu’ils puissent tirer
les enseignements de ce qu’il se passe,
améliorer le système.
Vous allez faire des vélos pour l'esprit.
Alors bien sûr,
ça ne va pas se faire tout seul.
Je ne vous conseille pas de le faire seul,
peu importe vos compétences.
Vous devrez vous entourer.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez le
développement logiciel, mais ça nécessite
plein de compétences.
Là, c’est le moment
où je vous donne plein de mots barbares,
des data scientists, des productoneurs,
des développeurs, des architectes.
Je peux tenir 20 minutes comme ça.
Mais ce qu’il faut comprendre,
c’est qu’en fait,
il est important de vous entourer
de tous ces talents-là,
et qu’ils comprennent bien
l’importance de ce que vous voulez faire,
l’importance du savoir-faire
que vous voulez démultiplier
supporter, développer,
qu’ils comprennent bien aussi
le potentiel de l’IA.
Pour que dans le développement
du logiciel,
parce que c’est plein
de micro-choix qu’on fait en permanence.
Où mettre le bouton ?
Qu’afficher comme information ?
Quel traitement sur les data ?
Quel data je prends ou non ?
Mais qu’ils le fassent en conscience.
Voilà pourquoi moi, je les appelle
les artisans de l’IA.
Les artisans sont des individus
qui exercent leur métier comme un art,
en conscience que ce qu’ils font
a une portée plus importante.
Voilà pourquoi, si vous avez identifié
une pratique, un savoir-faire,
que vous avez les bonnes technos
et que vous identifiez
des artisans de l’IA,
vous serez en capacité
de créer des vélos pour l’esprit.
Je peux même vous révéler autre chose,
vous serez même en capacité
d’aller plus loin,
de créer des applications
qui permettront probablement de répondre
aux enjeux de nos sociétés,
que ce soit la crise climatique
ou sanitaire, évidemment,
mais aussi les enjeux d’accès aux soins.
Démocratisation de l’accès aux soins
ou à l’éducation
et évidemment, les enjeux
de justice sociale
mais, tous les enjeux qui vous animent
peuvent être adressés avec
l’intelligence artificielle.
L’intelligence artificielle fait partie
de la solution, pas du problème.
Alors, pour finir,
je voudrais vous faire travailler,
vous demandez ce que vous allez faire
avec l’intelligence artificielle.
Toutes les technologies ont amené
leur lot d’innovations incroyables :
avec l’informatique, on a envoyé
des gens dans l’espace,
on a trouvé des solutions aux
crises  sanitaires et à d’autres crises.
Avec Internet,
on a créé par exemple Wikipédia,
un outil absolument formidable
pour partager avec le plus grand nombre
des savoirs.
Et l’intelligence artificielle.
Une chose est sûre, si vous m’avez suivi,
c’est que nous devons tous être acteurs,
pour répondre à ces enjeux.
Si on veut que les générations
futures regardent dans le rétro
et disent : « Ah oui,
cette génération-là ,
ils ont développé des choses
qui sont réellement un progrès humaniste,
ils ont développé avec cette technologie
des nouveaux services
qui nous rendent meilleurs. »
Alors peut-être que là,
vous vous posez la question :
« Je ne sais pas quoi faire
avec l’intelligence artificielle. »
C'est pas grave.
Mais le conseil que je peux vous donner,
qui est empirique,
c’est que si vous parlez autour de vous,
de vos idées et de vos savoir-faire,
si vous partagez ce qui vous anime
autour des enjeu
de notre société et autres,
je suis convaincu qu’autour de vous,
des artisans de l’IA se révéleront,
des gens qui viendront
adhérer à votre idée
et permettront de la rendre
concrète pour tous.
Une chose est sûre
en conclusion.
C’est que la balle est aussi
dans votre camp,
à vous de jouer.
Je vous remercie pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)